The Leopard 2 tanks are from Canadian
Forces bases near Edmonton and
engagetown New Brunswick they'll start
arriving this fall in Latvia right on
NATO's Baltic border with Russia
Canada's defense minister Anita onon
says their deployment demonstrates
Canada's resolve to defend NATO
territory let me be clear
Canada and all NATO allies will always
defend every inch of NATO territory and
we are deploying the necessary
capabilities and Personnel to make good
on that promise 130 Canadian Forces
Personnel will move overseas with 15
tanks to join the 600 Canadians who were
already in Latvia as part of a NATO
battle group it's a demonstration of
resolve we have this kind of capability
it is I think really important for
Canada to kind of Step Up and I'm glad
that the minister and the Canadian
Forces are doing this and yet it will
not be until the spring of 2024 when the
tank Squadron is fully operational
retired lieutenant general Andrew Leslie
a former tank commander himself is
disappointed it will take so long it
just points to how we need more
resources and more focus at the
political level to actually get things
done faster at NATO HQ in Brussels
Canada also announced it will give
Ukraine 10 000 artillery shells and 288
air defense missiles Canada will also
join its NATO allies in training
Ukrainian Pilots to fly F-16 fighter
jets David Aiken Global News
Ottawa